[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys very very careful today
we're going to talk about uh what's your
worst argument you have with your folks
um
worst argument i ever had my parents uh
was with me and my mom
actually it's with both of them
and uh man i i hardly remember what we
were even fighting about but i think it
had something to do with i had like a
friend who like overstayed his welcome
like he just kept hanging out way too
long and then my dad was like upset
about it like he kept sleeping over here
this was like this was back when we were
like 16 and yeah some dude who was like
he's one of those like pathological liar
guys that just like he was like the
boyfriend of a friend of mine so he just
kept hanging out but i think he really
ran away from home
so he was just hanging out all the
[ __ ] time and my dad was like dude
tell this guy to go home
and then uh
and then uh i just he was so cool that i
could i'm like this guy's so [ __ ]
cool
and then uh my dad was so pissed that uh
he was like i'm gonna take him on myself
so my dad like uh told him to like get
in the car my dad drove him home and it
turned out he lived in like [ __ ] san
diego or some [ __ ] so my dad drove him
to san diego oh my god i remember my mom
being really pissed about it because
like at the time i was still a little
[ __ ] and i was really combative and then
my mom started like yelling at me about
like how irresponsible is you don't even
know him you're letting him in the house
you're letting him do all this [ __ ] and
i got so uh pissed at her like i had
like a [ __ ] teen anger problem or
some [ __ ] so we start arguing like full
blast i start yelling at her and i don't
really
yell at her a lot i would kind of walk
away from bad fights at that age and
just not come back for a while but this
night i was super shouting at her and
then
she in the middle of our fight
literally had a heart attack oh my god
oh my god [ __ ] god that's just the
luck of having an argument with you i
guess
a heart attack yeah it was pretty what
did that look like
it just collapsed and then so she was
like
like in the movies you know how they do
exactly what you think it is
it's like that over overly dramatic like
it was like my left arm
grades of heart attack right there's
some that you're just [ __ ] done
you're gone and then like as you go down
like somewhere it's like discomfort and
then you oh and then you can't move hers
was it was a lower grade thank god but
yeah she she collapsed and i was just
like holding her and then how did you
process it was at first like what the
[ __ ] are you doing and then like oh [ __ ]
were you like i hope you don't think
that you won the argument because of
this [ __ ]
no it's like i think like it's one of
those things you you just immediately
like if it's your own mom like you just
immediately
forget about that's why it's hard for me
to remember what we were fighting about
because like that takes precedence in my
mind about that night and i was just i
called the um
one and i'm just holding her and i'm
like [ __ ] they get here in time and
she can't really speak she's like oh
it's just like hurts and then
from then on like i i mean the the fire
department they sent the fire truck of
course and the ambulance and then they
they took her and then um she
uh went to the hospital
and then
my dad came home oh
and then did he blame you for it oh 100
did even no
did you tell him like we were fighting
and then she got a heart attack so
mature of him by the way he knew
everything because like
i don't know i don't remember exactly
like if i told him or if he the hospital
like called them or something
i but then he just [ __ ] knew
everything and he came home and that's
like the i think one of
two times i've seen my dad cry it was
like at a funeral of my cousin and then
this time he was crying in front of me
and he was and i remember him like
he was like had like a murderous rage
and he was like
if anything happens to her i swear to
god and he was like gonna kill me like
literally holy [ __ ] she was that like
pissed oh my god and then uh she my mom
made a full recovery i think it was fine
since then i've never
uh fought with them again like that was
like 16. did that actually help your
guys's relationship
it did because i think it improved my
own [ __ ] shittiness like i just like
was like no what argument's worth that
what argument is worth like
seeing that happen like why do you think
why do things have to even get that
heated it doesn't and like when you
really look at a lot of problems at
least for me at the time the root of it
really was my dumb ass like that was my
fault i let this [ __ ] guy i don't
even know hang out with us so much and
sleep over and like you know this kid
was like a [ __ ] runaway like what am
i thinking you know but you don't see
any of that because when you're that age
you just you're just focused on being
the coolest [ __ ] guy possible coolest
dude sickest dude ever i'm not focused
on that now by the way yeah
i don't even think about that it would
hurt your like coolness to tell a guy
who you think is cooler than you that he
can't come over anymore it's like ah
[ __ ] i know and it's almost like they
took away your like best toy yeah it was
like your plate like your fun time it's
such a stupid thing tell me zack morris
can't come over anymore yes i wish he
was that cool
i uh i told my well
i found out
through the grapevine of my uncle that
my aunt have been talking [ __ ] on my
parents and my parents
have done some amazing [ __ ] like
my parents take care of my grandmother
my grandma's 90 [ __ ] two years old my
mom helps my grandma go to the bathroom
every [ __ ] day my mom helps my
grandma do everything every [ __ ] day
but nobody knows that because my mom
doesn't [ __ ] tell anybody doesn't
[ __ ] to them doesn't go telling them
all the [ __ ] she's going through all the
stuff that she's dealing with by the way
she's doing this [ __ ] and she had cancer
doing the [ __ ]
she's in remission now thank god
thank you seriously but like it's like
she was going through all this [ __ ]
right and this is pre-cancer stuff but
this is like a couple years ago but
still my mom is a saint right and so
hearing that my aunt was saying some
[ __ ] about my folks
like i went nuts right i went absolutely
not so you fought with their aunt oh
yeah i lit her the [ __ ] up i lit her
like a [ __ ] christmas tree
in the middle of july was it on the
phone or was it in the face no i i
texted her because i only had her number
on the on the text was there a lot of
bucks in there there's a lot of like
accusations
um
i basically just just said hey i heard
you're talking [ __ ] on my folks
you won't even you don't even deserve to
[ __ ] say their name
you know and i just let her the [ __ ]
have it
and uh my father was mad at me about it
because he felt like i got
in the middle of his uh my mom's
relationship with her sister
but i was like you know what if her
sister's a piece of [ __ ] who cares
but like you know i get it so my dad was
mad about that but i'm like you know
what like to me old man
you were supposed to do this not me
because that's a uh that's his job
that's your job to protect his wife
you're supposed to do that but i did it
instead so whatever and you know so it
was one of those things where
i really i don't have any regrets about
it i'm glad i did it
um unfortunate an unfortunate reality of
that is that
anytime some drama goes down in my
family now they try to keep it from me
because they're afraid i'll [ __ ] blow
this the equalizer
but dude it's just you know what like
my family's full of introverts i'm the
only extroverted person in my whole so
they all keep it to themselves all
keepers themselves they let build like a
[ __ ] huge mountain nice and i just
don't know how to deal with that i don't
know how to not say what i think and um
so i just that's that's my [ __ ] right
and i'm not saying i'm not sitting here
saying oh yeah what about us i am i'm
just saying like i that's just how i
deal with [ __ ] i have to release the
valve or i just think about it i can't
go to sleep so you fought with your dad
because of that one dad because of it
that was a pretty big fight yeah that
was the biggest one we've had i wish i
had a dad to fight with
but you don't even have one i guess that
was the last thing i did i told the
story here is i yelled at him and it was
very good yeah i wish he was around that
i can consistently yell at him every day
me too so we can mine contact for a
minute how is your relationship with
your aunt now
i don't talk to her at all he just cut
he just was honestly dead
very few people are dead to me in my
life what would it take would it take
her like apologizing for yeah but she
wouldn't own any of it she actually just
completely said that none of that
happens all [ __ ] oh she's denied
is she a narcissist who thinks that it's
never her face that everything that she
involves herself with is for the
betterment of whatever is she subscribed
i hope so she should um she should also
check out the patreon
um but no but it was yeah it's just one
of those things where it's like hey dude
you're just dead to me i don't care
there was enough going on like when i
was growing up with her
there was um
uh
my uncle bob who died
of aids
and he was gay so if you guys want to do
any age jokes and go ahead and get them
on your sister
maybe in a minute okay mine's more of a
knock knock than an aids joke okay cool
if you guys have any monkey pops you're
also just hitting me with that while i'm
down
oh you're down but
but no uh
but no he was a
an avid comic book collector like avid
right like he had like every [ __ ]
comic book he had like super boy number
one and [ __ ] and like superman number
one would have been tight but super boy
number one
that's worth thousands right
in action comics yeah yeah yeah it's
like a limited edition controller
unfortunately he mostly focused on weird
sci-fi [ __ ] so it's like you know we
have like it came from outer space like
number one oh yeah yeah a george mcfly
[ __ ] yeah george mcfly [ __ ] so it's like
great nobody collected this [ __ ] so all
the collect people who would have
collected this [ __ ] are dead
so thanks for doing that best buyers
don't exist anymore it's over
um but no but so when he died
um there was this huge dust up in my
family of like who gets what and like my
folks were like who gives a [ __ ] like my
dad actually went to
you know his house after because they
lived in pennsylvania or he lived in
pennsylvania and we lived in virginia so
like it was a short drive for us
compared to the family so by the time my
folks got there
all my relatives were there just raiding
the house getting his coins and all
those little [ __ ] [ __ ]
of [ __ ] [ __ ] right so
my folks are just like my dad was just
sitting there like just remembering my
great uncle
that's his brother no so that was my
grandfather's brother oh great uncle
yeah my great uncle right so then um
yeah so then by the end of it like we
got like i don't know carpet steamer out
of it like we didn't it wasn't about
came up it wasn't about what you get but
then the the idea was that we would just
split up the comic book collection
because who gives a [ __ ]
but then um
you know my aunt cleaned out his bank
accounts and like so she took like a
[ __ ] like all of his money that if she
was supposed to be because she's like a
super smarty teacher she was supposed to
be distributing all this stuff like to
the family but she took it all instead
and just said like what a mess oh no he
left it all like no no no this is what
he wanted and all this [ __ ] but that's
not what he wanted for her only for her
only and so it's just like this [ __ ]
thing that like money matters more than
family all this stuff [ __ ] so by the
time that we get to this part of like
hearing that my aunt talk [ __ ] on my
folks i'm like you're done [ __ ] yeah
for you it was already the breaking
point that keg's already lit that strike
[ __ ] four he's like i better hear i
better if she does it again
maybe he's so used to her [ __ ] that at
this point it's just a cycle but to me
i'm like this should have been you you
should have done this yeah i'm not
emasculating him i'm just we're just
different people what was your dad
saying
back at you when you were telling him
you should i got between my mom and her
sister i shouldn't have done that i
[ __ ] things up for them but now my mom
is like yo my sister's a piece of [ __ ]
because she's done a bunch of stuff
since then to prove it even more right
than like
seven years six years ago does your dad
agree that it was his job to do that
before you [ __ ] said i won't say that
to him oh you didn't tell him that's
your job oh i don't want to destroy his
soul
i am petty but not to my father i love
my phone oh that's interesting
you spared him that way i did that's
good i i think a little bit differently
where
um
i hold grudges with my family members
and i make them pay
so like it's different you've done
something
um
but i maybe you know
it's not as severe as what your parents
did or something like that so maybe
um i like to see them suffer a little
bit and then i can forgive them i get it
yeah so like i remember like you know i
didn't have the best relationship with
my mom and all that stuff and then um it
got to the point where she started to be
more understanding of me as a human
being so like we fought all the time um
and she was a great mom in the sense
where like she did her best with the
knowledge that she had
you know like being in a conservative
christian household you're stubborn you
don't think outside the box you don't
think of other ways to parent you just
kind of blame your kids right so then no
matter what
there was never a discussion about
anything it was just you're wrong and
you're possessed by the devil
and then so and i think i was super
mental
but then but then eventually like um she
got to the point where like after my dad
left and all that stuff like she had to
look at herself and and then you know
there comes a time when it's like you
can't just keep blaming people uh
for why something's not the way you want
it to be like she would blame my brother
for influencing me she would blame my
dad she would blame all these other
things right but then she's like i never
thought that there will be a time where
i would be alone with no husband and all
this [ __ ] and then now i'm like
distancing myself from my son so she had
she had a huge like wake-up call and i'm
like okay i'm gonna let you marinate in
that first second because some people
would be like no no you know what that's
that's that's okay like no you're a
great mom but for me i was like i'm
gonna let you suffer for the next five
years until i'm gonna give you any
affection yeah and then and then to me
that journey for her she was like you
know going through counseling she was
reading books and then she would cry and
call me up and be like you know
i [ __ ] up and then like i heard the
apologies and i'm like that's good
that's good i think i need a couple more
years of this holy [ __ ] yeah and then
but then she wasn't the only one i did
this to
my uncle beat the [ __ ] out of me when i
was a kid um because he was embarrassed
that i got lost in this church thing
right and after that i s you know
i i was everything clearly labeled
was no directions
for anything no i i yeah
i guess i was uh
the campus cops found me
and and i was just eating cake hanging
out and i guess
we were making friends and [ __ ] right
and then when my uncle came through i
didn't know he was embarrassed he did
the whole like laughing and then when by
the time they you know he took me to the
tent he beat the [ __ ] out of me so i was
like i was screaming up a storm was he
then so like i [ __ ] yelled like crazy
right and then like all the people were
coming out and they're just like what's
going on stop that [ __ ] and he got even
more embarrassed right oh yeah what the
[ __ ] it's way worse right right
and i milked that [ __ ] i was like yeah
he was hitting me so much he's gonna
make this [ __ ] go to jail and
then so like it like my parents begged
me to [ __ ] change the story
i was like all right and i was like i
can't wait to [ __ ] spread this rumor
at church i'm gonna [ __ ] this guy and i
was like one day
i'm gonna get big like my body's gonna
be big and i'm gonna [ __ ] this [ __ ] up
and that's all i obsessed about and then
i was like one day i'm gonna get bigger
and then last couple months ago he had a
heart attack and then i was just like
thinking
hey dude you shouldn't keep getting so
angry all the time and a piece of me was
like saying like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
that's what happens when you have an
anger problem
but the other piece of me is like dude i
love this guy he was a gangster bro he
was a great [ __ ] uncle there's a part
of you know like not all abusers
apologize for what happened oh no he's a
narcissist like he never dude he's same
thing like my dad
he's your dad's brother he's married to
my mom's sister okay so so same thing
like with my dad right like his he had
an intervention with my my cousins who
are his kids and they're like you used
to beat the [ __ ] out of us you threw me
in a closet and let didn't let me out
for like six hours like you tortured us
driving a blood uncle
yeah so so then so then so then they had
this intervention and he goes i never
hit you guys oh same [ __ ] god
repressed his marriage all this stuff
right
so then they're like unless you change
you can't see our kids
that's what they said to him yeah holy
[ __ ] and then so for me like completely
changed like he doesn't [ __ ] with me
anymore like i love the dude like we
have conversations but then i still
enjoy mentally [ __ ] with him
sometimes and be like remember when you
[ __ ] me up like it was fun wasn't it
yeah and then it's like and i'm just
like dude and we'll just be eating and
i'll be like yeah isn't it awesome that
i pursued my dreams and didn't have to
listen to your like kind of advice
because if i chose what you wanted me to
do
and you kept pressing me to not like
pursue things like i would have failed
at life right and then he would have
been and he was like yeah you know i
realized that people should all pursue
their dreams and all of his kids are
like that's what we've been [ __ ]
trying to tell you
i just watch this and i'm like
that's right [ __ ]
like jk will be dead within a year
but like i don't know like like like
that pettiness of me of just like
i want to torture this guy oh even
though i i care about him it's such a
weird feeling
it is weird it's a conflict yeah i don't
know but i don't fight with them i love
them i know they change and i feel like
people all
have like these different
kind of demons and weaknesses once dad
pisses bart off yeah i was telling him
like uh in between the break i was like
damn i'm like i'm like fighting with my
dad like every day right now currently
now currently right now so i actually
don't even know what the like
message or the lesson is because it's
not it's it's all muddy it's not i
haven't articulated even a thought
process yet but it just feels really
good to yell at him
i know that feeling that wasn't me
yeah so we just sold like literally
every day how much are you hanging
though huh how much are you guys hanging
what do you mean like i'm living in your
spot right now right how much do you see
him well he lives with us yeah but like
we don't we don't really like that's
what i'm saying yeah we live so i see
him every day
and then every day he talks to me about
the same [ __ ]
and then and then i give him answers to
the same [ __ ] and then he goes oh that's
really good and he goes back to his old
thoughts so i think that's the part that
it's like you're living with joe
maybe i don't know
i stopped my scooters all the time dude
yeah
can't stop talking about scooters
but yeah but i think i think my dad's
actually a narcissist
like
like after talking to him now i'm like
holy [ __ ] i'm like you're not listening
to me this guy really can't uh
because like everything that he talks
about like he'll do something and he
blames the other person for not taking
it the way that he wanted it oh like he
was like i don't understand like
everyone wants this i'm like no not
everyone will do he got he got [ __ ]
butt hurt at me because he made me that
red bean dessert and i didn't eat it
every day yeah like the biggest thing of
the red bean dessert i should have ate
it every day and i told him oh this is
sick right and then after that every
[ __ ] day he had a big bowl of it in
the fridge and i was like [ __ ] dude
after like seven days of it every day i
can't eat it no more yeah he can't he
hasn't pooped you know and he he said he
got his feelings hurt because i lied to
him that i didn't [ __ ] like it
and i and i and and i left it in the
fridge and i'm like who makes a dessert
with legumes
it's [ __ ] delicious it's pretty good
but not every day right not that much
not a big bowl yeah right now the uh the
biggest thing is um that we're dealing
with
is my dad had this crazy epiphany
that he wants to get back with my mom
oh that's a real thing and they got
divorced when i was six yeah so my dad
was like hey you know what i've been
thinking and then he's like
i'm like 70 something i'm probably gonna
die on my own her mom is like 70
something she's probably gonna die on
her own he goes like why do we even need
to do that there's two people perfect in
this world for each other and he's like
you know what i see
i see like me your mom
gio
taika and you just sitting at the dinner
table and we're just having a nice
family dinner and i told my dad i'm like
you know that vision that you have i'm
like out of the seven billion people in
this world i'm like you know how many
people have that fantasy it was how many
i'm like just you
know what
no your mom doesn't think like this i'm
like no she want a [ __ ] cause you're
at you dumbass i'm like she's [ __ ]
living her own life she was stuck in
taiwan for [ __ ] two or two years
because the pandemic she did she text
you once no she comes here does she text
you once she hates him dude give me her
awesome buddhist [ __ ] life right and
she was like no your mom needs someone
to take care of i just know it so it's
just one of those things where it's like
no matter what evidence you prohibit
you're manifested enough you're like for
for him it's like
you should tell him to write poetry it's
a tv movie for him so he's actually
gonna try to pursue this like he's gonna
put some action into it yeah like
everything he's like okay like i'll talk
him out of it right like why it's a dumb
thing to do yeah and then he goes all
right all right let me let me think
about it and then the next day i'm like
cool you thought about it so what's it
like goes like man
your mom 70 me
70 we're gonna die a lot it's like the
same dude it's it's [ __ ] jlo and ben
affleck yeah exactly [ __ ] stuck in
his brain so the data doesn't change
even though you don't even speak and
then as soon as she starts talk so
they've been talking and then she'll
tell me about all these things about how
like my mom's unhappy with him and he's
unhappy with the way my mom wants
they've been texting now yeah so like my
mom was like all right if you want to
come back into her life she's like uh
here's like a coat of conduct you have
to follow oh she's like we're gonna
[ __ ] have this contract this is the
most bart [ __ ] i've ever heard about
how it comes from
when you come back into my life you're
not coming back in as my husband because
you [ __ ] that up for over 30 years
you're coming in as bart's dad you get
to stay in the front room and here is
the contract that we're going to live
we're going to be friends but we're not
going to be like romance partners and
after you sign we're going to get this
[ __ ] [ __ ] notarized and if you [ __ ]
up i'm kicking your ass out of here damn
you gonna do a notary why do you have to
do it just to get a third witness just
to get a third witness that's the most
bart [ __ ] ever too yeah it's all so
barty and yeah so i was like and this
one you know where it comes from yeah so
he'll explain all that to him like
that's why she's like is your mom crazy
i'm like but you knew this
you knew who mom was and you already
know that this is what she's gonna come
back like why do you expect her to act
differently yeah i'm like no one thinks
the way you do no one thinks the way mom
does both of you guys are crazy as [ __ ]
you guys have never got together but how
nice is she to actually even consider it
i know draft a contract with a notarized
contract exactly right because there's
like an inch of her saying
i'll try this out yeah you know like
computerizes the word
that's [ __ ] wild i'm in the middle of
it i don't know what to make of it just
yet it's just [ __ ] i was like oh [ __ ]
i think my dad's a narcissist bart bart
it's christmas day
year is 20 23.
one 2023 three okay you're there it's
geo you taika your mom and your dad your
dad's carving the [ __ ] christmas hat
he looks at you
and he's like told you folks you
[ __ ]
he said seven leads in your mom's ear
and he's like
she's like she's like oh my god oh my
god
later later she goes by the way we
haven't announced it
[Music]
the first ever
[Music]
you